it is unbelievable how lies that are
told by the social justice left just
become quote unquote fact they are
laundered as fact through our
fact-checking apparatus and through our
media and no one seems to care
so one of the things that we have been
following here pretty closely at the
daily wire is the new standards and
practices set up by facebook so facebook
admitted that for the past year they've
been suppressing conservative content
essentially which we've known because
we've seen our own traffic statistics
some of the metrics that they use in
order to determine what stuff to
suppress is quote unquote fact-checked
material and they say this openly now
that if something has been fact-checked
even if what is fact-checked is
quote-unquote missing context they will
just downgrade the distribution of that
material now missing context is a
designation that fact-checkers left-wing
fact-checkers frequently use in order to
ding conservative content that is not
untrue so we print a true story
and then politifact says missing context
by which they mean that what we said is
true they just don't like that what we
said is true and then facebook
downgrades our content
and meanwhile the fact checkers let
complete lies just go
just utterly unquestioned in the
mainstream media
which again plays back into
the facebook metrics okay facebook gives
credit to quote unquote widely trusted
sources well what makes a source widely
trusted what makes a source widely
trusted is that it isn't fact checked
that's what makes a source widely
trusted so legacy media have basically
re-enshrined
their own monopoly on disseminate
dissemination of information via the big
social media companies like facebook
that's why they were pushing facebook so
hard right all these big companies the
new york times and the washington post
they have columnists who spend every
single day just pushing facebook to
restrict dissemination of information
whether it's the hunter biden story in
the lead-up to the election or whether
it is conservative coverage of the
border all that stuff has to be
suppressed
and the way that they do that is they
have these quote unquote non-partisan
fact checkers ding every conservative
outlet and let open lies by the
mainstream media go and just pretend
that these open lies by the mainstream
media do not exist like this is the
shtick and it is really really effective
because when you when you launder bad
news through the system it magically
becomes clean and when you launder
actual factual reporting from the right
through the system it becomes quote
unquote missing context okay perfect
example of this so over the past
week and a half
there's been this viral photo
there's a photo that went viral of an
agent a border patrol agent supposedly
grabbing an illegal immigrant and you
can see his quote-unquote whip ugh ugh
he's whipping the illegal immigrant
i guess a haitian illegal immigrants
who's rushing across the border and
apparently into the interior of texas
you can see this border patrol agent
leaning over his horse right this is the
viral photo wow and from his hand the
border patrol agent you can see that
there is a rain that is dangling
now the media started reporting over and
over and over again that border patrol
was whipping haitians
and you remember maxine waters saying it
was worse than slavery
he had columnists coming out and saying
this was reminiscent of slave catching
patrols
systemic racism and now is alive from
the very beginning border patrol agents
do not have whips there is not a single
agency of the american government that
is armed with whips and that is not a
thing
a border patrol agents have horses those
horses are controlled by long reigns as
anyone who has ever watched a western
understands
again not a horseman over here but even
i understand that you need reins in
order to control a horse
but because the border patrol agents had
rains and the rains were long the notion
was that these border patrol agents were
either using full-on whips to whip
people or they were using the reins in
order to whip people
okay
all of that
was a lie not a single part of that was
true so here was the still photo and
then it turns out as i said remember i
said that there somebody had video of
this because there are tons of reporters
at the border that turns out somebody
did have a video of this of this exact
incident with that picture here is what
exactly happened on the video on there
for you if you can't see
so you can see there's border patrol
agent he's ordering people out of the
river
he's yelling at people he's trying to
turn his horse right he takes the reins
and he spins the reins in order to turn
the horse and here is one of the haitian
illegal immigrants and there's there's
one of them and he's running up the hill
he's gone right he's making his move up
the hill the border patrol agent
literally leans over off his horse and
grabs the guy by the shirt
and that right there is the entire damn
it
that's the whole thing
what you just saw is the most
controversial policing procedure since
george floyd in america
i'm not kidding that that is
what it has been right
hey this is the single most taken and
most distributed photo about law
enforcement since the george floyd
scandal of a year ago
now in that particular case
george floyd died beneath the
knee of a police officer
whether or not you believe that it was
causative
in this particular case
an illegal immigrant was crossing a
river illegally tried to run into the
interior of texas a border patrol agent
leaned over his horse and grabbed his
shirt
that's it you saw the whole video
that's the whole thing
still is what went around that rocketed
around the world not just rocketed
around the world but became the topic of
every major media show
have any of these major sources
been fact checked on this
any
they've all had to go back and issue
corrections now
but that doesn't matter apparently
the new york times for example
put out this correction an earlier
version of this article overstated what
is known about the behavior of some
border patrol agents on horseback
while the agents waved their reins while
pushing migrants back into the rio
grande the times has not seen conclusive
evidence that migrants were struck with
the reins
okay it turns out that waving your reins
at your horse is what you do when you're
riding a horse so that's not a story
what's the story is when you smack
people with the reins but that didn't
actually happen
hey and by the way the journalist who
took the photo
said uh
no i never saw anybody whip anybody
the photographer whose name was paul
rachey was speaking with ktsm
he said he and his colleagues taking
photos that day never saw any of the
agents whipping the haitian migrants
they were moving
some of the haitian men started running
trying to go around the horses says
ratchet
he says quote i didn't ever see them
whip anyone with the thing he was
swinging it i didn't see him actually
whip someone with it those definitely
can be misconstrued when you're looking
at the picture
okay but that did not stop the democrats
from ripping on border patrol for over a
week on this
here was joe biden ripping his own
border patrol agents by the way you know
what to stop the border patrol agents
from having to do any of this a wall
a wall here here is joe biden ripping
his own border patrol agents over a
complete hoax it is just not true over
myth-making
it was horrible what to see as you saw
to see people treat it like they did
horses really running over people being
strapped it's outrageous i promise you
those people will pay
they will be an investigation underway
now and there will be consequences
there will be consequences it's an
embarrassment but it's beyond an
embarrassment it's dangerous it's wrong
it sends the wrong message around the
world or sends the wrong message at home
it's simply not who we are
it's simply not who we are oh you know
who we are is a bunch of senile liars
apparently again this whole thing never
happened it never happened
according to the mainstream media the
hunter biden story was a russian
disinformation operation but our border
patrol agents were openly whipping
people
uh our fat checking media by the way
will tell you and they spent a lot of
time doing this a couple of weeks ago
afghan the taliban were not hanging
people from helicopters that wasn't a
person who was dead hanging off that
helicopter that video that you saw of
somebody hanging from a helicopter the
taliban would never do anything like
that and then a week later their stories
that the taliban are literally hanging
people from cranes in the center of
herat
but you know they're not going to get
fact-checked on that
but
what is absolute fact according to the
entire democratic administration is what
is clearly and overtly a lie it is a lie
that border patrol agents were whipping
people it is not true there is not one
iota of evidence that this ever happened
and every member of the bible
administration parents this every single
member
kamala harris who's just
woking it up over at the white house
here she is saying the images of border
patrol evoked slavery
i was outraged by it
i it was horrible and um and and deeply
troubling there's been now an
investigation that is being conducted
which i fully support and there needs to
be consequence and accountability uh the
human beings should not be treated that
way and as we all know it also evoked
images
of some of the worst moments of our
history
where that kind of behavior has been
used against
the indigenous people of our country has
been used against african americans
during times of slavery
what in the world is she talking about
these are people illegally trying to
enter the country
not people who are attempting to
evade the country they're trying to come
into the country these are people who
are trying to cross the border and claim
asylum so they can live here
they're trying to get into the place
that the border patrol is trying to keep
them out of
birth and trying to recapture them and
take them to a plantation
like what in what in the hell is she
talking about and it's just a lie again
it's just a lie okay but they don't care
about the lie because the lie forwards
the notion that they are part of the
constant revolution
right this is this is the bigger point
the bigger point is that when it comes
to democrats democrats are interested in
the lie that
they have to do two things
simultaneously which are impossible okay
on the one hand government can cure all
your problems government can keep you
safe from coven government can pay all
of your bills government can protect you
from all this vicissitudes of life
government is the be all end-all
on the other hand
the government is racist the government
is systemically evil the government is
discriminatory okay so these two things
can't go together right over the course
of the 20th century these two strains of
progressive thought were in complete
conflict
the authoritarian top down we can solve
everything progressive caucus and then
you had the authoritarian bottom up
progressive caucus which suggested the
entire system needed to be overthrown
the compromise come to during the obama
administration was perpetual revolution
from the top
right the notion was that if we take
over the powers of government we will be
almost outsiders in our own
administration we'll sit here ripping on
the structures of government until we
can use our power inside the government
to change the structures of government
so this is why you see the weird
spectacle of members at the top of the
white house ripping on the border patrol
agents are part of their own executive
branch
how can they do that
because this is part of the entire
strategy which is we are the perpetual
revolution and give us power we will
make we will remake the system from the
inside along the basis of racial equity
right this is barack obama's claim and
democrats have picked up on it
democrats for a long time said no no the
system is good you just need to put us
in charge and give the system more power
now democrats say the system is bad put
us in charge and give us more power
that is the goal here
alejandro mayorkas the dhs secretary
doing the exact same thing these are
images of systemic racism
in the midst of meeting these challenges
we
our entire nation
saw horrifying images that do not
reflect who we are
who we aspire to be
or the integrity and values of our truly
heroic personnel in the department of
homeland security the investigation into
what occurred has not yet concluded
we know that those images painfully
conjured up the worst elements of our
nation's ongoing battle against systemic
racism
these people are a damned joke they're a
joke they've been a joke for years by
the way going all the way back to
michael brown who's still perceived in
in large swaths of the progressive
community as some sort of secular saint
right michael brown attacked a police
officer before he was shot to death okay
this is the the
basic idea here again is that all that
matters is the narrative and the facts
are of complete non-importance they do
not matter to this administration they
don't matter in the slightest and by the
way you're not supposed to pay attention
to the fact that this administration
which said that it was not open borders
took ten to twelve thousand of those
illegal immigrants there are fifteen
thousand people under that bridge ten to
twelve thousand of them have been
released inside the united states didn't
even get coveted tested by the way i've
noticed we've got vaccine passports
everywhere and now we're mandating that
healthcare workers throughout the united
states get vaccinated or get fired we're
telling businesses with more than 100
employees they must vaccinate or test
their employees once a week
but if you're an illegal immigrant come
on in no covet test for you here's
alejandra mayorka saying 10 to 12 000
illegal immigrants have been released
inside the united states
of the 17 400 that weren't deported back
or didn't return on their own to mexico
how many of them either
well first how many have been released
into the u.s uh they're released on
conditions and approximately i think
it's about 10
000 or so 12 000 have been released yes
and of the five thousand that are still
in process
we will uh make determinations whether
they will be uh returned
uh to uh haiti uh based on our public
health and public interest uh
authorities
so they they um they deported like five
people
everybody else got it
every single other person was just
released into the interior of the united
states
yep but it's not open borders guys
they're not open borders i mean i know
that you're sitting there going to
yourself well didn't trump want to build
a wall and all yeah they oppose a wall
you see
why did you allow them in the country in
the first place why didn't you build
forgive me a wall or a fence to stop
them from walking in this flood of
people coming across the dam it looks
like a highway that allows them to cross
the rio grande it is this the policy of
this administration uh we do not agree
with the building of the wall the law
provides that individuals can make a
claim for humanitarian relief that is
actually one of our proudest traditions
oh one of our proudest traditions is
people crossing the rio grande illegally
being housed under a bridge and then
being released into the interior of the
united states of the show up again date
it's a it's a proud tradition in the
united states that that's good to know
but here's the thing guys it's not that
they hate the patrol it's not that they
hate the border patrol alejandra
mayorkas also says the border patrol can
count on them
if you're a border patrol agent why
wouldn't you just act like police
officers all over the united states have
been acting and be like you know what
done i'm gonna sit here i'm not doing
anything because the minute i do
something and a photographer takes
something i do out of context
my career is over i'm done so i may as
well just sit here you want these people
in the country anyway fine fine we're
just going to not do our jobs we're just
going to sit here and if you want people
to cross over done
i'm not going to participate
here's alejandra mayorka saying the
border patrol can count on them after
every major member of this
administration from the president of the
vp to the secretary of homeland security
is out there lying openly about members
of border patrol
can the border patrol count on you and
president biden who has said the people
will pay
to come to an a determination based on
the facts
and and not based on twitter outrage
they sure can and let me say uh
something about that jake because i've
worked very closely with the men and
women of u s customs and border
protection for many years many many
years
and i they are heroic
they're heroic wait a second i thought
they were members of the systemically
racist posse rounding up black illegal
immigrants they're heroic they're
the same message that the democrats give
with regard to the police they're heroic
except if they do their jobs and then if
they do their jobs and we take pictures
of them doing their jobs then they're
racist heroes of the kkk
it's just a pathetic administration
no wonder their popularity is declining
radically as well it should be this is
an administration in very very serious
trouble if all they get to show for it
is just a giant bag of spending even
that is not going to be enough
i hope you enjoyed that clip from the
ben shapiro show if you did go ahead and
hit that subscribe button so you stay up
to date with all our future content